now you could be forgiven for being a
bit tired of hearing about the Irish
border the reason they were talking
about it so much is that it's the big
obstacle holding all the breaks that
deal so with the Irish problem central
to the talks let's now talk to you these
shallow Northern Ireland secretary Tony
Lord because Alford thank you for being
with us today
welcome Sophie nice to speak to you
and now yesterday we saw around 700,000
people march in favour of a second
referendum of course I know that
Labour's position is that you'd like to
see an election but with the prospect of
No Deal rising something that would
really impact and people where you are
now in sulfur's would you prefer to see
a second referendum if it's a way of
avoiding No Deal I think what so
Labour's made very clear is that the
first thing we've got to have is
something that the government are
resisting which is a meaningful vote in
our national parliament and that's
really important because we can't simply
have a rigged vote that says it's Teresa
Mel's bad deal or or no deal
even if Teresa may actually is able to
negotiate that that deal we've got to
have the capacity for Parliament to say
that there is a choice round the
national interest not the political
interest of a divided Conservative Party
but and what we have said clearly would
sooner there was a general election we
need a government quite frankly that's
got a commonality of purpose not the
present government which is relying on
the splits in the Conservative Party to
be cobbled over we have said though in
the end we're not ruling any auction out
if that's the way of breaking the
deadlock we can't force a general
election the parliamentary mathematics
say that what we can do is to insist
though that the that there is proper
debate around the real choices that this
country faces and that's at the moment
what the government's are resisting you
can see why some people would think that
by saying you're not ruling anything out
you're effectively sitting on the fence
I know you're more comfortable talking
about meaningful votes or the need for
other elections but if there was a
second referendum how'd you vote would
you vote remain relief well we're not
that are we we really aren't there what
Labour has said
is that we want some we want one of the
the referendum on barrettes it wants and
negotiate that the brexit deal that's in
the national interest and yes of course
that's the the border across Ireland
it's also making sure that we don't have
a hard border down the Irish Sea it's
making sure to be quite honest we don't
have a hard board round a northern town
like Rochdale that I represents in
Parliament because what's really is
important is that we see that the what
is the national economic and political
interest put ahead of the factions
within the Conservative Party so we're a
long way from consideration around the
referendum it's great to see people
demonstrating in our society
legitimately always of course we're a
free society and we ought to respect and
value that but in the end as as the
political party we've got to give the
public the legitimate choice and that's
through parliamentary democracy it's as
the meaningful vote has got to be the
next step okay and now island of course
is front and center of the Brits that
negotiations and this week the Shadow
Chancellor John McDonnell said I'm a
Republican I long for a united Ireland
but I recognise democracy so as their
shadow Northern Ireland secretary what's
your view do you long for a united
Ireland
I long for respect for the Good Friday
Agreement and natural fabless what John
McDonnell said John like everybody in
the labor parties well he's the Good
Friday Agreement it did indeed but but
John did say this he respected the Good
Friday Agreement the contract agreement
was Labour's creation we're not going to
run away from that that's really
important because it's important
actually now in the context of the
debate on the the Irish border the
reason we can't have a hard arish border
is because it would run it would do
potentially massive damage so what the
Good Friday Agreement achieved which was
peace after so many years of bloodshed
and conflict but we're equally clear
that the there can be no constitutional
change the position of Northern
Ireland's past the United Kingdom and
unless that's the choice the people in
Northern Ireland not been ultimately of
course in in the rest of Ireland
we can't allow brexit to do damage to
the Good Friday Agreement the price
would simply be too high now that's not
really just my opinion when I quote as I
do the Chief Constable George Hamilton
of the the Northern Irish Police Service
who said that any hard border would give
potential targets for those who would do
us harm when he goes on to make the
point that that puts people at risk then
we've got to take the idea of no
hardboard and not simply as a matter of
political rhetoric it really is about
not going back on the Good Friday
Agreement and the peace process okay now
moving on to a few other issues
Universal Credit is something that we've
been covering extensively on the show
and I was hoping you might go to clear
up for me what Labor's position is on it
because I know originally it was paused
and fixed then the shadow chancellor
came on the show and said he thought
that the system was broken and should be
scrapped and then last week Shami
Chakrabarti seemed to say that actually
it was just about looking at the
structure and the name of universal
credit rather than scrapping the whole
thing so what is Labour's position
are you saying that you should just have
another look at universal credit or you
saying that actually the whole thing
should be scrapped no well first of all
let me say I'm delighted that that you
this guy have been covering the
universal credit because what's
happening to people in terms like my own
is really an absolute disgrace we're
poor prising people who are already
struggling these aren't the the work
shown they're lazy these are people who
very often working families but a
struggling need that little bit of help
and having the rug pulled from
underneath the feet so within that what
I think we're very clear on is the fact
that the universal credit as it simply
cannot do the job what Labour will do in
government and I hope we're in
government soon enough to implement this
is to say we need a root and branch
review now of the Social Security reform
it will be things for example like
Labour's commitment to bring in a
meaningful living wage because that does
change the the context in which the
benefit system you might you might keep
it and resume it universal credit sizes
you
versal credit sizes simply is not fit
for purpose so as part of that reform
and universal credit as is simply can't
be allowed just to stay okay
now I also want to talk to you about the
really horrific child grooming cases
that we've seen sixty men jailed this
week in Huddersfield and I'm interested
talk to you about it because you of
course were previously the Greater
Manchester Police in crime Commissioner
and there was of course this abuse ring
in Rochdale as well now yesterday Sky
News spoke to one of the victims in
Huddersfield he said she believes that
this is still going on with your
experience do you think it is still
going on would it surprise you well it's
it's very hard to say it's not good
nothing quite honestly but what we do
have to give is a signal from every
public agency and everywhere else that
in our society we won't tolerate this
type of outrageous criminality sexual
abuse of young people changes their
lives and may change the lives forever
I've met victims over the years of
sexual abuse and you can see the damage
even many years on that it does so there
can be no web compromised and they can't
anymore be any acceptance by public
institutions that there's a tolerance
that perhaps that probably did exist in
in the past one of the things that I
must be proud of that we did in Greater
Manchester following on from the
position in Rochdale was to insist that
there's a very different way now of
dealing with them with sexual abuse for
young people and that involves every
public agency working together and not
working separately it makes a big
difference because it's about bringing
together those little bits of
intelligence that maybe the police have
maybe a school has maybe the Health
Service has but when you see them put
together gives a bigger picture and
allows us to challenge the the
perpetrators and to protect the
vulnerable I can never say to anybody
that no child will be sexually abused
what I can say is what we've got to make
sure that all our public agencies will
stand down with absolute determination
and see this as one of the top
priorities protecting our vulnerable
young people